In the Council building,
all 27 Member States
meet and discuss European policy issues
and try to find a common position.
We have different kinds of meetings.
We have experts, we have ambassadors.
They meet at minister level.
And finally, of course,
Heads of State and Government
as the so-called European Council.
For all these meetings to be successful,
you basically need two ingredients:
policy advice to the presidency
and logistical support for the meetings.
I think probably the best way
to understand how we work
is to see a European Council in action
from backstage.
It's going to be a difficult
summit meeting. They always are.
I spend a lot of time
making phone calls to capital cities.
I attend quite a few
internal organisation meetings
as we work very closely together with
the Council's General Secretariat.
I am very focused and I am focused
because much is at stake.
The future of our currency,
our economy,
and we have to take all this
very seriously.
It takes us five days
to prepare for a summit meeting
and three days to dismantle everything.
We are into the Italian language now.
It's 25 pages, each language version.
My main responsibility is to prepare,
in this case, the treaty,
which will be signed on 2nd March.
Today we are preparing the text.
It should fit perfectly.
This is a signature ceremony. You want
it to run as smoothly as possible.
That's the simple reason
why we're doing this.
Ready to go.
So yesterday both Juppé and Hague
referred to the possibility
that the Arabs would table
a new resolution in New York.
I say that we should include
in the points of his speech,
in the introduction, external relations,
Syria, the Arab Spring.
There is, of course, one subject
which is still under discussion.
So we have to wait for
today's discussions
because there may still be
a couple of problems around.
We have a high-ranking visitor with
the President of the European Council.
It's the President of Serbia.
Things are not over.
Serbia didn't achieve candidate status.
We will try to fix the problem,
probably this evening.
If it is not possible,
we have to discuss it
at the European Council, Thursday.
There are always problem files that
need sorting out at the last moment,
that's typical.
There is positive confirmation
of the criteria being met.
But the decision is not being taken.
I have a meeting with the Director
General of the WTO, Pascal Lamy.
Hello.
- Herman.
How are things? Fine?
- Fine is going a bit far.
We'll remove those two there
and leave ten here.
That's the entrance but
Van Rompuy and Barroso will be here.
The idea is to put the flags
next to the chairs.
A camera that gives
a wider establishing shot.
I'm looking for the best places
to position the cameras
in order to have a clear shot of each
Head of State as they sign the treaty.
Apart from the Heads, plus one,
no one will be standing up.
Finland.
Germany.
The top line in there
is the bit about trust.
I'm the President's speechwriter,
which means I prepare his important
speeches and press conferences
and try to find the right words
to fit the man and the situation,
often in close consultation with
Mr Van Rompuy himself.
So then I try to reorganize it
around the three key words:
crisis, trust and confidence.
Enlargement will be on the agenda,
as well as further accession
to the Schengen area.
You pull that way and you pull that way.
Move towards them. Lift it up,
don't let it touch the table.
And put it down. Put it down.
There you are.
We're assembling the table for
the Heads of State and Government.
It's a big table,
more than 11 metres long.
We need a single tablecloth and
everyone available to help put it on.
Is any sort of video streaming planned
for the signing ceremony
of the Fiscal Compact?
The summits are the big thing
for all the journalists here
and therefore it's also the big thing
for us, the spokespeople.
We will try to make what is agreed
on Syria available quickly.
There are always some last minute
surprises, but also matters
that the President or an assistant
needs to personally smooth out
at the last moment before the meeting.
We have to wait and see.
It has to be issued this evening.
Everything is well prepared.
But 27 people always have to agree
and that's the big problem.
There are always surprises
and you always have to improvise.
We are here today on the eve
of a European Council.
Practically, I'm responsible
for making sure that tomorrow,
when the Heads of State
and Government come,
they have all they need
to do their work.
It's like running a small village,
making sure that everything is there,
so the leaders can take
the right decisions.
We always have to be
ready to serve them.
The flowers and everything
have to be in place
for the arrival of
the Heads of State for the dinner.
This meeting is with President Barroso
and President Van Rompuy.
We are planning the day, basically.
Good morning.
- How are you? Nice to see you.
Let's go through the agenda
of the European Council
tomorrow morning.
If you could make it
a bit wider than that.
European Council is not much different,
in terms of concept,
from any summit that could be held
anywhere in the world.
The difference between
all of those and us
is that we do it
on an almost monthly basis.
Fiscal consolidation remains unavoidable
to keep our social model sustainable.
It is a very busy day.
It will end after midnight.
Mr President, we have good news now
concerning the candidate status.
They have reached an agreement
and signed the meeting protocol,
and we hope that this will pave the way
to a decision without discussion.
I think so.
Because everyone is right-handed.
They'll contact me.
Only the escorted vehicles
will enter Rue Froissart.
We have a number of participants
in this room, as you can see.
We have the local police
for the outside perimeter.
We have the federal police
for escort purposes.
And we have the Belgian
special forces in the house,
for a protective mission
for a country on a higher threat level,
but also for interior protection.
We have people on the roofs
and people on standby,
close to the main meeting room.
All these people together coordinate
things in case of a major event.
A very big day for you.
Have we got
any interesting relays to take?
I welcome you all to this meeting
of the European Council.
The most important thing about
interpreting is not the words,
it's not the language itself,
it's the message.
It's the spirit of
what's being put across.
We have instantly to understand
what people are trying to say
and to convey that message
in the same tone, in the same spirit.
Let's get started.
We're almost there,
we'll be there in 30 seconds.
It was tough!
- It was tough.
I am very honoured that you have
all decided to ask me to continue
as President of the European Council
for a second mandate.
Today we have 1,800 accredited
journalists in the press centre.
There is a lot of information
flowing in this area.
From delegations,
from institutions, etc.
More or less informally,
and therefore we have to try
to always keep things in context,
try to give them indications about
what is being discussed, about timing.
With regard to a press conference
after a summit meeting,
the trickiest points are often
negotiated right up to the last minute
and the latest news is then provided
at the press conference.
During this Council, we have
a wide range of issues to discuss.
Continuing this work for Europe
in such decisive times
is a privilege and a great
responsibility. Thank you.
There will be a day of reckoning
for this dreadful regime.
I'm Chief of Protocol
and one of my tasks is to welcome
all high-ranking visitors
here on the red carpet.
I studied psychology
so that helps me somewhat in this job.
You have to go up to them
and be cordial.
That means I'm a bit of
a Doctor Feelgood.
We're in the OB van and are filming
the arrival of the Heads of State.
They can arrive in any order so we don't
know who it is, it's always a surprise.
Stand by, camera 5. Zoom in.
... and achieve
a politically united Europe.
Stand by, 1. She's going
through the door. Stand by, 6.
I'm going to come up with the pool now
for the table round.
Let's go.
The most difficult moment is when
the Heads of State come into the room.
The media wants
slightly more interesting shots,
which involves a lot of rushing around.
That's why we're there.
To stop them and
tell them to be careful.
It went really well.
Everyone signed, as you can see.
It took about 4 or 5 minutes
to go round the room, so...
Short and sweet.
It's a done deal.
What you see here are dedicated teams
of translators and assistants
servicing, exclusively,
the summit meeting.
Everyone wants to get,
as fast as possible,
the versions in their own language,
which allows them to give
the conclusions a final check.
We should start in about 5 minutes.
I'll place you on hold until we start.
Hello everybody.
What I'm doing now is a debriefing
for the European Union
Heads of Delegation abroad
because our Heads of Delegation
have questions, of course.
They must explain what is going on
at the European Council.
With this treaty
we have established balances,
balances between
responsibility and solidarity.
See you afterwards.
Congratulations!
There were some difficult subjects:
Serbia's application to join
the European Union.
It wasn't clear at all
a few days ago
but we managed to iron out
all the problems.
So you could say
I'm a happy and satisfied man
after these two very intense days.